hey everyone we open my channel I'm
currently live-streaming fallout 76 to
do basically a live review what I'm
gonna do for the next couple of hours
also is effectively review fallout 76
but out loud I will say everything that
I would usually write down when
reviewing a game for companies that I
work for like IGN Kotaku and the various
magazines that I've written for so that
you guys get an idea what the process of
reviewing a game like this is like okay
we planned the game we're playing it get
[ __ ] you
you're really gonna start with this like
I'm not already signed in and I have to
do this live on stream is it going to
show my boss but okay what's what's the
deal here oh this is just like the
fallout 4 character credo huh this is
MIT way easier on console it's strange
facial hair face facial hair no that's
wrong this is not good so I'm not
enjoying this character how are you
gonna have this many AI types and have
them all be this bad I've already done
that I can't see that again why do you
look so high okay is it an eyelids issue
is that what it is I think it's gonna
have to do hey Owen is this oh my god he
looks so baked okay where'd you go
what where did he go what what happened
what the [ __ ] did I break it
where did he go no no no no what ever
secret [ __ ] well we found our first bug
I guess I can't [ __ ] take a picture
because he's gone I'm trying to zoom out
okay oh what's that vibrating you're
doing what okay that's good I mean it
looks pretty good that is very delayed
why does it take so long is this a
minigame
okay I mean it's kind of cute I guess
ooh all right I'm feeling it yeah wow
this is a really nice vault I'm like not
used to seeing them so pristine okay
pitbull II like that animations hand
looks good so someone on Twitch mention
that this looks like an indie title and
not a triple-a and I think that that is
actually how we should be looking at
this game we should be looking at it
like oh Jesus Christ like it is a
low-budget like not like it's a core
series and I think a cool Fallout game I
think that Bethesda kind of screwed up
by marketing that as though it is I mean
so far I think this environment looks
great
the Lighting's a bit off yes I know
everyone can hear me talk I realized
that and I'm going to say that I think
that that is a huge floor of this game
is that that isn't push-to-talk meaning
that while I'm streaming everyone just
gonna hear everything that I can say
especially for a multiplayer game it's
almost like they've never made one but
then Elder Scrolls online exists and is
vaguely successful I don't know
more [ __ ] for me you more free [ __ ] I
like this well building so far I think
the setups very cute and that's weird to
have a Fallout game when you can't
inspect every single locker
I couldn't even drink from the toilet
what game am i playing alright roll on
out here loading screen really all right
let's get in it told me to press T but T
didn't do anything so why would you have
that animation do that what a weird
choice get out yeah I'm trying get out
okay was it supposed to be animated both
ways and just wasn't I'm gonna try that
again
okay so it just missed an animation on
him going in the first time he just
walked into it
Wow how do they have this many bugs from
the from the get-go I know everyone said
it was broken but damn Bethesda
I feel like fallout 4 looks better than
this
it just looks terrible it's like someone
put a blue filter I mean that's exactly
what they did
oh hello rads Dokdo you got it Wow Wow
bad mm-hmm it just looks so old I
generally don't care though I suppose
like you know whatever I'll take all
this Oh what did I do
I take it back Game of the Year I'm just
gonna do this until it's said do it for
long enough to get us some kind of boost
so there we go well tuned nailed it okay
this is terrible so there's this thing
that keeps happening if I sprint and I
go forward it works but as soon as I
move in any direction it stops printing
I guess it's striping stops printing
it's also if you press shift before you
press the W key
he doesn't sprint but if you do it the
other way around it works whereas most
games just press shift means sprint no
great I really do like the color though
and it's not like there isn't any
attention to detail it's pretty dense
you know things are obviously kind of
decaying out here like that's pretty as
old as it looks I don't like the blue
but that that's more of a personal
Egyptian gonna do a UH like a hard rule
no it's not like I don't already see I
don't I already have that that that
full-out sense of discovery that is you
know exploring the wall Oh oh jeez what
Oh God already had that full that sense
of discovery where you're coming across
something and there's enough detail that
I'm like curious about whatever the
thing is and I want to find out more
about it and I definitely get that oh it
wasn't that interesting but it was a
place hello what are you doing the world
has enough stuff in it you know I am
amazed that we've already seen two bugs
like everyone said it was buggy but I I
always assumed me internet as
overreacting when it comes to bugs but
damn this game should be annoying access
all right are you players are you I
think you're all gonna be actual animal
news I just want to do some looting hey
okay
scorched
stupid like how did that not me okay
I feel like every facet of this is
broken where are you actually like why
would you not be kidding me bad AI okay
well thanks for the stuff I guess I mean
I'm supposed they're just introducing me
to enemies right now but collisions were
off they went
hitting me properly
who was he even shooting at it the
animation didn't gonna look like he was
shooting let's check this out again I'm
glad there are like different things to
check out but I haven't found any of
them particularly interesting so though
this is just an exposition dump just one
very long exposition dump
boo corrupting alright let's give this
shot
I mean I don't need anything but that
seems like an interesting enough
mechanic though or an interesting enough
crafting process
I can make a hatchet let's do it let's
make a level-one hatchet okay that's
pretty simple it's easy I understand the
menu so right now this just feels like
the same as any other fallout with
slightly west music and mall bugs which
is saying a lot because I haven't even
seen another Playa boat boat boat boat
boat what did i do what did i do did I
step on a crap what was that what did
that where are you ah okay don't blend
in how are you 1 1 3 when you add that
much it easy to kill them okay no I
don't mean where is dogmeat
this is cute and the sound design is
pretty good because it's a Fallout game
so they've just used the same [ __ ] that
they've always used which I'm fine with
oh that's no [ __ ] NPCs are you just
gonna make me chase this [ __ ] and I'm
never gonna find out it's another log
yeah the mini it's not great to control
on PC so power that would be an aid
so ever not responding great excellent
just what we wanted all right
she's trying to drink some water I guess
we're not in the game anymore
fantastic oh wow wow wow wow oh wow oh
it's so bright the filters I don't care
this is very long and I recognize that
you're trying to make me care but the
voice acting is bad and it's not very
interesting
written and so I have to pull it out of
my inventory again you automatically
tested it that's good I appreciate that
you did that analyzed the water testing
kits results okay this is just busy work
but it's fine yeah hello hey hey what's
up hey hey hey
like a hat it's cool hot you have that
it's really interesting things you're
doing right now oh he's gone thing is I
don't have really have any reason to
find out the players like it's the thing
with this game just that everyone is
sort of existing and though in the same
world while following the same
uninteresting level design like is that
what's happening because I guess my
question is why I'm sure if you put
people who know each other into any game
they're going to have fun literally
anything from each oh hello how's it
going I'm good how you doing doing all
right you'll never believe it I was
watching your stream and you found me
yeah well you look a lot cooler than me
damn is that just Kalorama that you've
modified
it's like a mid-level quest item if you
would like to be a leader level of okay
so there's a couple of different powers
right so you're familiar with xo1 okay I
played fancy ones mm-hmm yeah so that
stuff's like late late game and I'm not
there yet even though I'm level 50 it's
not so much a spoiler you stumble across
it if you get on south towards like that
mining facilities that big ol red mining
facility on your map see those three
stands that looks like yeah dinars yeah
it's like right there yeah you get an
idea could I go down now or do I have to
like plan that out I mean you could um
they're gonna spawn a super high levels
like if you or I were to team up right
now I think they spawn like at 50 and
that's not
you know get it over so well with you
I'm gonna do a power level pretty quick
but yeah I think you want to make it
wait
yeah that's fine thanks for saying hi
what do you think thanks man
yeah have fun okay everyone mental
acuity but uh agility well since you
guys I'm mentioning it I'm gonna mix
with strength guess I'm just gonna keep
on going on this uninteresting main
quest I like the level system I think
that that's pretty solid it's it works
pretty well hello please don't make me
kill this Brahmin so much I'm sorry bud
love you what God he's just glitching
right through it and why does it shake
so much whenever I use combat that was
awful just not at all fun no one had a
good time here
alright let's keep going hey [ __ ]
let's see how this feels on festival
fine it's not it's not great
I feel like it's Sholay it's better with
gun I just at this point all right
[ __ ] I think I'm just mostly bothered
by the animations it just fully goes
through them it doesn't look like they
they're being hit at all which kind of
sucks
oh it's irradiated up in here oh that's
[ __ ] great alright great let's do
that much damage
[ __ ] you take my whole life should've
stuck with God a melee weapon really say
it for that long with the rash it's got
a shutdown that Oh your head came off
that's fun
I wait for the melee weapons holy [ __ ]
there are a lot of you regret regret
regret I [ __ ] up
Piper evolved it does a lot more damage
let's give it a shot see how it goes hey
what are you doing what are you doing
what are you doing man
you gonna there we go okay you figured
it out you sold me alright that was easy
oh [ __ ] he's coming that looks bad
look at that that was like mspaint I'll
take your head [ __ ] alright surely this
[ __ ] up here that I want right oh look
it's fire watch you're gonna get a phone
call from Delilah that's I think that
that is my biggest criticism is that it
feels pointless and I really don't want
to jump on a bandwagon and just hate a
thing that everyone else hates with the
sake of it but I'm unimpressed and of
course if I were you know actually
reviewing this rather than just
reviewing it by playing it by myself I
would I would be playing with other
people when making an effort to do that
but as its dance there are plenty of
people who don't have friends to play
games online I don't have that many
friends who will be playing fallout 76
actually I doubt I have many at all I
just got [ __ ] stuck on the side of
that didn't I so yeah stand alone I
would say don't play this by itself
right now it feels like they made a
sandbox and wanted to make sure
multiplayer worked and then everything
else was an afterthought I think it
would be way better with NPCs it would
give you direction at the very least it
would have more character and you know
people do get attached to NPCs in games
that's absolutely a thing I don't
because the rat don't [ __ ] with us I
guess well no they're all just standing
it like a memos have NPCs that people
really like but they didn't think they
needed to for whatever reason everyone's
just dead and you're just kind of
wandering by yourself in an empty world
it's really odd okay well I know there
aren't gonna be MPC's here that's that's
another dumb pot it's like investigate
Morgantown yet boy I already know there
aren't gonna be any goddamn NPC's here I
know that that's not going to be a thing
because I played this goddamn game how
long this takes
oh wow you shot me and your guns not
even facing me it's not even facing me
it's facing up that's not how weapons
work it's just that's such a weird thing
if I know that no where is going to have
NPCs what do I care about a desperate
Cole over a radio of them saying they
need help I'm not at all compelled to
investigate something when I know that
nothing is here the menus do look nice
and the sound design is good like the
stuff that pathos has already been good
at for a long time it's good still
continues to be good the weirdest part
of it for me is probably that it doesn't
if it's trying to be rust
Oh Daisy which I get those games are
super fun
it misses what's fun about those games
which is interaction between people it
doesn't have any of that charm so my
leading question is why why why does
this exist look at you go right in sync
riveting combat experiences her role
come on buddy
yo you'll figure it out yo oh they float
while floating now and that's cool all
right well got a running jump on that
one
no is exciting thank you everyone for
joining
we got 1944 what makes it which is
really cool
I'll try playing it again with other
people and I think if I were to actually
review it that would make me feel
differently about it in that I'm sure
it's a different experience and it's
designed for that kind of play but I
again would argue that it should be able
to standalone by itself there should be
more players to make it more fun by
itself so that you're at least having
interaction one person I found found me
from the stream the other two people
didn't that Mike's so it was just kind
of pointless it just feels like an empty
fallout where there's no real reason for
you to chase down anything unless you're
listening to audio logs and reading
texts and I just don't I'm not feeling
it not feeling it